hace poco menos de una hora y media el
gobernador demócrata de este estado de
pensilvania parece haberla aclarado un
poco dando una estimación de que
podríamos tener que esperar hasta este
viernes como comentaba es para conocer
esos resultados una fecha a la que
parecería que también se podría sumar a
wisconsin en ese lento conteo de votos
aquí en pensilvania como os decía el
gobernador demócrata ha hecho una
intervención ante las cámaras ante los
periodistas ha dicho que con estas
elecciones se está poniendo a prueba la
democracia de este país y se está
haciendo un pulso contra los valores
fundamentación ales de eeuu ha dicho que
no descansará hasta que terminen de
contarse todos los votos porque cada
persona cuenta un voto y todos van a ser
contados en estas elecciones aquí en
pensilvania de momento con un cerca de
un 65 66 por ciento de los votos
escrutados como decía es la victoria va
para donald trump en este caso también
ocurre un poquito lo que estabais
comentando en las grandes ciudades como
pittsburgh a 15 y decían de nosotros nos
encontramos ese voto se inclina más
hacia el lado
demócrata mientras que en los suburbios
a las zonas más agrícolas del país del
estado iría más el voto hacia el tono
altran pero como decía es hay que
esperar hay que ser prudentes para no
adelantarnos en estos resultados ahora
lo que sí que están empezando es esos
cálculos matemáticos de cuántos estados
o cuántos de zonas necesitaría ganar
cada candidato para llegar a esa cifra
mágica de los 270 votos parece ser que
tram necesitaría pensilvania a pesar de
haber conseguido esa florida y ese
triunfo en algunos estados claves del
sur algunos estados clave del sur y del
sureste del país invaden podría llegar a
esos 270 votos electorales haciéndose
con wisconsin michigan y nevada